- So Kelly, one thing that
I see on a lot of browsers,
they might have like a private
mode, or an incognito mode.
What do those things generally do,
and how private, or incognito are they,
and what should we still think about,
even if we are using those modes?
- So, generally, a private
mode, or incognito mode means
that what is happening
in that browsing session
on your computer stays there.
So, sometimes when you browse the web,
you get things like cookies
that remember who you are,
remember different things
that have happened,
so for instance, a site that
you've visited it before,
maybe that you've logged in before.
So what those windows do is they say
that once you close that window,
everything is forgotten on your computer.
But what they don't mean,
is that no one can know what happened,
because they don't protect against
other software running on your computer.
If you're at work, your work administrator
might still have access to
what's happening on your computer
or even the Wi-fi network
might have some sort of record
of what traffic's going through it.
- So to clean out a lot of the things
that might be saved on your computer,
when you're normally browsing.
And what are the disadvantages
of using that mode?
- The disadvantages are,
some of the things that cookies
do are conveniences for you.
So for instance, if
you remember your login
on a website, that makes it much easier
for you to log in next time.
Or maybe, you want to
have your video service,
remember what videos you like,
so that it can give you
better suggestions next time.
So, the internet, there
are a lot of advantages
to some of the things like cookies.
It's just a question of,
in that particular moment,
is that something that's useful to you?
Or is that something that you wanna avoid,
by using a private or incognito browsing?
- Super useful. Thanks so much, Kelly.